[Music]
nothing's too big when it comes to cardi
b's daughter
to celebrate culture turning four the
rapper throws her little girl a magical
mermaid themed party and you have to see
the details
look at this cake
the cakes get better every year
we agreed the colorful cake is a work of
art and the decor gets better too as
cardi gives an inside look on instagram
we're talking real-life mermaids posing
by the pool
[Music]
hi baby
the under the sea themed party was a
kid's paradise ball pits bounce houses
[Music]
plus a painting area for culture's
closest pals
[Music]
there was even a custom beauty bar for
kk's friends so they could match her
pink and blue fishtail braids
cute by the way this is my house and of
course the whole thing was a family
affair
offset culture and culture's brother
wave were all there staying on theme the
mom of two matched her mini me in a
mermaid ensemble with colorful pink hair
she's so precious seriously but before
cardi and kk took a dive under the sea
they got the party going in a major way
gifting the four-year-old with some mad
cash
it's a ticket a ticket is a million
girls
50 say 50.
yup 50 000 in cash for culture oh
snappity snap snap and the famous spam
hit up candytopia an art exhibit
featuring creations completely made out
of candy
you're ready to get at the boy
good job kk
and the marshmallow pit
[Music]
looks like she had a blast but my
favorite moment when culture had the
sweetest reaction to seeing her mama on
display as candy art
[Music]
yeah
it's like
love joy it's a
switch
you know what i'm saying there's like an
automatic smile she's like she loves me
and if this is culture's fourth gotta
say we can't wait to see how cardi out
does herself next year when kk turns
five
[Music]
you